300 équipes adultes 180 équipes jeunes
reportées en raison de la neige le
baïkenron 2013 aura finalement tenu
toutes ses promesses ce week-end on va
s'amuser plus qu'autre
chose un chrono passer du bon temps
voilà tout simplement
un parcours d'environ 13 km dans le parc
du château de Versailles autour de la
pièce d'eau des Suisses VTT et course à
pied en équipe au delà de l'aspect
physique la compétition met également
les neurones à contribution à quel
moment effectuer le relais avec son
binôme quelle est la meilleure tactique
à mettre en place ce qui est important
c'est de dans les dans les run and bike
c'est surtout de préparer avec son
coéquipier les changements de vélo
notamment pour avoir un peu une
stratégie en fonction des parcours c'est
ça qui est le finalement assez important
si la plupart des concurrents venaient
en amateur les sportifs de haut niveau
ont signé de bonnes performances une
occasion pour eux de préparer les
prochaines compétitions de triathlon à
la victoire revient audio Ferreira
combalousier en 44 minutes et 15
secondes
hop effectivement j'ai gagné les quatre
éditions précédentes avec quatre
équipiers différents l'idée c'est que
j'essaie d'avoir toujours un cinquième
un équipier différent par année mais je
suis un jeune papa avec un petit garçon
un petit Noé de 11 mois et je suis passé
on va dire de plus de 15h d'entraînement
par semaine à 5 donc c'était pas du tout
fait j'ai eu un équipier hors norme
cette année et puis c'est vrai que le
back and run c'est quand même une de mes
disciplines de prédilection qui
correspond à mes qualités physiques
c'était un parcours assez assez beau
avec des des bonnes côtes à monter aussi
des rêves une grosse côte de trois
sonnettes c'est raide ouais il y avait
beaucoup de beau c'est glissant t'as pas
d'appui ouais c'est c'est assez dur
prochain rendez-vous à Versailles le
championnat de France avec le triathlon
du roi les 11 et 12 mai